سنتحرك الدائران حتى لو كلف ذلك تصعيدا مع
امريكا طبعا بهذه الجمله ودعا نتنياهو
منصبه رئاسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه قبل
حوالي العامين و بعنوان احباط مساعي ايران
لامتلاك سلاح نووي
بمقدمه اولويات الحكومه يعود نتنياهو الى
ذات المنصب اليوم بعد مصادقه الكنيست على
تشكيلته بعد ان حصل على تاييد ثلاثه 63
سلطه
المهمه الاولى التي يصرخ بها الاعضاء هنا
ولكنهم يلغونها كما لو انها ليست مهمه هي
التاكد من ان ايران من تقضي علينا
بالقنابل النوويه يعني احباط جهود طهران
لتطوير ترسانا نوويه تهددنا وتهديد العالم
باسره
[موسيقى]
بعد عودته من جديد ايران اولا وثانيا
وثالثا هذا ما ستركز عليه حكومه نتنياهو
الجديده التي ادت اليمين الدستوريه اليوم
رغم تعرضها للانتقادات واسعه بعد ان تضغط
عليها سمه اقصى اليمنيات المياه
العسكريه طبعا لمنع ايران من تملك سلاح
نووي يهدد ليس اسرائيل
جاء خلال استعرضه الخطوط العريضه لبرنامج
حكومته الجديده امام الكنيست الاسرائيلي
طبعا كان نتنياهو قد اعلن تعيين يوقف
جالنت احد مساعده بحزب النقود وزيرا للجيش
ويعاد جالنت الذي كان قائدا سابقا للجبهه
الجنوبيه احد المؤيدين المخلصين له
لنتنياهو وقد شغل ايضا عده مناصب وزاريه
في الحكومات السابقه التي تراسها